in the early 1800s an English nobleman
in the county of Worcester hired two
local chemist John Lee and William
parents to duplicate a sauce he had
tasted while traveling in India the
resulting concoction was unpalatable
so they relegated it to the cellar years
later they came across it during a
cellar cleanup and gave it another taste
lo and behold the sauce had matured and
was now delicious they christened their
creation Worcestershire sauce and went
into business today more than 170 years
later that same company produces that
very recipe the specifics of which
remain a closely guarded secret the
process begins with onions and garlic
pickled and malt vinegar for one to two
years inside the pickling barrels the
bulbs slowly liquify their flavor
infusing the liquid
other barrels contain anchovies cured in
salt for several months additional
ingredients include salt sugar white
vinegar malt vinegar tamarind
concentrate molasses and a top secret
blend of flavorings and spices starting
with the two vinegars workers pour the
ingredients one at a time into gigantic
blending tanks there goes the tamarind
concentrate now the anchovies
you
the ingredient proportions are
top-secret as is the prescribed mixing
time between ingredients now the pickled
onions and garlic
sugar and salt
and that secret blend of flavorings and
spices next they pump the mixture into
maturation tanks they're over the course
of several months the ingredients age
and interact with each other undergoing
complex changes in their natural
chemistry which produce the sauces
distinctive flavor agitators rotate
intermittently to keep the ingredients
well blended the sauce then goes through
a sieve then through a press followed by
another cycle of blending and straining
the sauce is a smooth liquid by the time
it progresses to the next phase
pasteurization this process heats the
sauce to kill off organisms ensuring
optimal flavor for at least 18 months
the sauce needs no artificial
preservatives whatsoever because the
vinegars it contains our natural
antimicrobial agents